bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france des représentants religieux ont
donc appelé au calme au sénégal appelle
visiblement entendu mais pour combien de
temps effectivement c'est toute la
question en réalité l'appel des
religieux a permis justement à
l'opposition peut-être de mieux reculer
pour deux heures plus tôt de reculer
pour mieux sauter je crois que le
président de la république et le pouvoir
ne pouvait compter que sur si vous
voulez la puissance et l'entregent des
confréries musulmanes qui sont très
puissantes et qui opère justement au
sénégal comme comme je dirais qu'ils
opèrent dans la régulation de la
modération des conflits et donc le le
fait que les religions puissent
intervenir aussi souligné que les le
clergé catholique aussi à 2,2 de la côte
bleue de la même personne qui devait
avoir lieu aujourd'hui mais en réalité
en réalité je pense que ne le dit que
dans les semaines qui vont venir qu'il y
aurait encore inaugurée dès ma
libération et compacté et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ousman sonko et les
membres de l'asso défis vitaux ce qu'ils
attendent ce matin je sais moi que le
président de la république
ils attendent que le pouvoir donc que le
président macky sall tu sais restaurer
l'état de droit puisque non seulement à
libérer libérer il ya eu plusieurs
détenus à tchernobyl qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont raison car il ya pas moins d'une
cinquantaine de détenus politiques qui a
été au delà il ya eu il ya eu plusieurs
blessés
il faut quand même aussi rappelé que
dans ces manifestations il ya eu onze
personnes qui sont mortes et 11 pour
ceux qui ont été fauchés donc je crois
que c'est samedi justement a permis à
peut-être au fond c'est l'opposition et
à la société civile pour recharger les
batteries et qui sait peut-être que dans
les jours à venir y aurait des
manifestations et après faut voir il
faut voir l'ampleur et vous vois dans
les conditions dans lesquelles ces
manifestions au rayon pukki et par ces
accords nous avons assisté le 8 et le 9
mars avec eux avec des blessés par
centaines et malheureusement aux
personnes qui ont été tuées
les opposants ont transmis un mémorandum
de 10 points qu'est ce qu'il contient
précisément dans ce mémorandum les
points le point de vue le poids le plus
évident je sais moi c'est celle à la
libération des détenus
pour tout vous dire plus avant dans le
parti de rousbal soccoïa où il ya plus
de 17 hommes qui ont été accueillis hier
prisonniers de plusieurs vous êtes le
plusieurs semaines et on ne sait rien
je ne sais rien à propos de ces femmes
yahia il ya une peur qui est un opposant
qui est qui est très connu qui m'a russe
sagna qui justement est emprisonné
depuis plus de trois semaines on ne
s'aime pas là où il a d'autres
les fonds marins sommes essentiellement
on demande à faire et qu'on six mois a
demandé à ce que le prix le le président
plus rapidement libéré ces personnes que
l'écart prisonniers et aussi qu'il
annule toutes les poursuites qui sont
les conseils contraires aux smart locaux
et puis il ya un point que le rap et le
point saillant un peu le no10 justement
du côté du pouvoir c'est le nom au
troisième mandat la constitution du
sénégal aujourd'hui elle ne permet que
deux mandats maximum
mais aujourd'hui le prix le président le
président macky sall et son essor
parties entretiennent un flou donc à
réalité les opposants justement vont
même si vous voulez là toute la pression
qu'il faut pour qu'il n'y ait pas un
troisième mandat comme on a pu le voir
en côte d'ivoire ou en guinée avec les
risques sécuritaires que cela engendre
alors les sénégalais installé en france
demande à emmanuel macron d'intervenir
ils manifestaient cet après midi à paris
on a vu les images
est ce que le gouvernement français a un
rôle à jouer dans la résolution de ce
conflit au sénégal et quelle est la
position sur ce sujet des manifestants
ou sénégal effectivement le l'heureux
quoi la france c'est quelque chose de
paix habituel mais mais mais quand il
était rouge vraiment les manifestants au
sénégal ils se disent que c'est pour le
sénégal aux sénégalais donc il n'ya pas
il n'ya pas le leur courage à
m'accrocher se masser c'est peut-être si
vous voulez un effet de mode souvent
dans la tête de la diaspora mais quand
vous interrogez que soient les partis
politiques les manifestants au sénégal
personne ne demande à la france
d'intervenir il se dit 7 c
c'est un sujet que c'est légal ou
illégal est donc il ya que les
sénégalais coup le régler merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions ce soir régis on paie analyste
géopolitique et directeur exécutif
d'interclubs conseil